[موسيقى]
المخدرات والكحول والطقس الدافئ والهواتف المحمولة في سيارات الدفع الرباعي
وفقًا لدراسة جديدة ،
هذه هي الأسباب الكامنة وراء زيادة
وفيات المشاة ،
وتقول جمعية سلامة الطرق السريعة للمحافظ إن أكثر
من 6500 شخص لقوا مصرعهم وهم يسيرون على
طريق أو بالقرب منه في عام 2019 وهذا هو
الأعلى  منذ عام 1988 ، سجلت ولايتي كاليفورنيا
وفلوريدا وتكساس أكبر عدد من
وفيات المشاة بين عامي 2009 و 2008 في سن المراهقة ، حيث ارتفع
عدد المشاة الذين يُقتلون سنويًا
بنسبة مذهلة بلغت 53 في المائة بينما
زادت جميع الوفيات المرورية الأخرى بنسبة
2 في المائة فقط من كل شيء بدءًا من الطقس الدافئ الذي
يشجع على المزيد من النشاط الليلي مثل
المشي و  يرتبط بزيادة
الشرب إلى عوامل تشتيت الانتباه عن
الهواتف الذكية ، كما تم ذكر الزيادة في المركبات الأكبر حجمًا
في الدراسة
، كما ذكرت GHSA أن
إلغاء تجريم الماريجوانا في
عدة ولايات هو عامل محتمل ،
لكن الدراسة لا تناقش
ذنب ومسؤولية
المشاة في الدراسة  يقترح أن
تركز الدول والمجتمعات المحلية على
الإنفاذ  منة التعليم الهندسي
والاستجابة للطوارئ من أجل
التعامل مع المشكلة في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا أليسا مطر